[Applause]
when you say you start meditating
that's something that's uh that's deep
man you know what i'm saying you've
lived a lot of life for being
your age bro like what got you into
meditating and like
kind of give us a little bit of game on
what that is because i don't think a lot
of people
i think people hear that and they see it
on tv and they think it's like
some like weirdo like hippie [ __ ] yeah
but talk about what the what the
meditation [ __ ] is
it's really like it's really peaceful
it's like
um like sometimes you want to feel alone
you want to be by yourself or something
right right so you would go in a room
away from people you would normally be
with us on right
and you would think that this solving
the solution because you isolate
yourself but really like the peace to
find that peace
is like when i meditate i find that
peace i'd be looking for like i'd be
distant
from the world from this world the
little fake [ __ ] we living in i'd be
distant from that [ __ ]
and i just be with myself with my
thoughts and i be controlling my
thoughts
you know just saying what i want and i
just speak like i already have it
i'd be talking like um i'd be praying at
the same time i meditate uh
um i'd be doing a lot of [ __ ] i'd be on
i just constantly telling myself [ __ ] so
when i get out of there meditation
that's my mindset
and this is what i'd be working to you
know it just changed your way of
thinking it
it reprogrammed your brain like todd
[ __ ] like hey you better gonna
[ __ ] this yeah what purpose what got you
into like starting to do that like was
it a certain person or did it something
you watched like what got you when
you're starting to do that
uh i i kind of caused a video you know
and i was just wondering like no i
always been like i've been getting like
spiritually woke like i be seeing angel
numbers and [ __ ] i don't know if you
know what they mean
but like you'll probably see angel
numbers yeah you you will see it after i
talk to you i bet money you're gonna see
it
but it's like i started seeing angel
numbers and a whole lot of [ __ ] and like
oh no it's like spiritually it's like
when once you do [ __ ] spiritually it's
like you unlock different levels
it's hard to explain it just come it
just kind of me and like
it come to you in like different
chapters type [ __ ] it's like here
he'll go a new tool to get through this
chapter you know and then
i just stumbled across a video damn
something my mouth
i stumbled across the video and started
my meditation i tried it and bro i ain't
gonna lie
since i tried it man i've been like
straight i'm gonna be giving nobody
the time of day you yeah
[Music]
yeah i know the last time we talked i
was telling you like yo man like
you're you have like you can have 10
years
20 years in this game you got the talent
like you're dope don't let none of the
other
outside negative like because you know
when i like obviously
i was up on like shadow flowing like
some of the earlier [ __ ] you would put
out but
i had known you more initially for just
the [ __ ] i would see on
on instagram like you arguing with other
rappers or whatever and i'd be like man
this
this kid is dope and it's dope to see
you like
level up mentally you know what i'm
saying because it's going to extend your
career bro and it's going to like
make your quality of life like so much
better and that's really what it
at the end of the day the money and all
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] don't matter if your
quality of life is solid
that's real really true happiness you
know what i'm saying and like that's how
you can extend
you know you could be one of these
rappers i mean a lot of your peers that
were around a year and a half ago when
you was
first popping they ain't here no more
and if they are
no one cares like they used to so you
know what i'm saying so
i think you've done a good job of um
growing man for sure